uboya a ensuite voulu se lâcher
l'affaire Lola le racisme le gars tout
mélanger et c'est surtout pas là là il a
dit des choses très très grave voilà et
c'est ça qui a fait que ça c'est revenu
mais parce que Louis Boyard ne peut pas
dire ça d'ailleurs sachez-le on va
poursuivre en justice oui Bahia non
seulement pour ce qu'il a dit ce qu'on
l'avait il dit qu'ils ont la incité à
dire des choses dans l'émission que
j'avais des choses donc ils sortent les
SMS et on va l'attaquer pour ça et on va
l'attaquer également pour ce qu'il a dit
là regarde
on a même pas le droit de critiquer
qui fait des choses qu'est-ce qu'on fait
pour les gens toi qu'est-ce que tu as
fait pour les gens toi qu'est-ce que
j'ai fait pour les gens il y a 200
personnes
ou quoi tu prenais ton cachet tu faisais
le malin toi tu prends ton cachet tous
les jours
l'actualité sur la qualité
du mal que vous faites au pays avec le
racisme
franchement tu penses pas les gens à
nous tous ici au public au dominer aux
gens qui regardent on n'a pas le repas
alors vous voyez je suis plus que calme
jusqu'à présent et quand il nous reste
dire qu'on fait monter le racisme on inv
pas toujours tout le monde ici fou et ça
je vous le dis et c'est des gens comme
Louis Boyard qui font monter le racisme
ils sont montés sur tout le
communautarisme qui font monter les qui
montent les uns contre les autres ce
sont des comportements comme celui-là
nous on est voilà on est d'accord on
n'est pas d'accord sur plein de trucs
avec Julien avec Carl
avec toutes les personnes qui sont ici
je vous dis voilà mine de rien avec les
LR aussi on s'est pris la tête
Pierre-Henri c'est vrai mais on discute
on parle on dit voilà on n'est pas
d'accord sur ça comme on peut faire et
on essaie de trouver des solutions je
vous dis eux ils votent mon avis que
Louis Boyard et je mets pas toute la
lsfit dedans puisque voilà Jean-Luc
Mélenchon est à part c'est lui qui est
venu en premier ici donc euh voilà c'est
lui le premier homme politique qui est
venu dans l'émission donc ça je peux pas
lui jeter la pierre mais eux pour lui
Boyard il faudrait qu'on invite que des
gens de la fille avec ses idéologies et
son idée allez si possible que lui ça
c'est ça c'est un support et quand il
nous traite à nous quand il nous dit de
faire monter les racines ou de faire le
buzz sur Zemmour il faut qu'il comprenne
un truc j'allais le traiter encore
heureusement vous avez vu voilà je vais
pas avoir de proposer
on traite des sujets qui font
l'actualité malheureusement pour lui
Éric Zemmour en l'an dernier il a fait
parler lui pendant des semaines et des
semaines donc forcément à la fin de
personne exactement on a parlé d'Éric
Zemmour si Valérie Pécresse avait fait
parler d'elle on aurait parlé de Valérie
Pécresse tous les jours un moment Marine
Le Pen on a parlé énormément d'elle
parce que
Emmanuel Macron quand il est il est venu
ou pas on a parlé lui donc voilà mais
quand on vient chez vous oui on sait où
on met les pieds bah oui quand on vient
chez vous on sait on met les pieds et on
sait qu'on est capable de tout dire vous
voyez quand je revois cette séquence et
je vais l'ajuster après je pense que le
Boyard il s'est cru dans l'assemblée
mais nous à l'Assemblée on a ça tous les
jours on a ça tous les jours et il faut
supporter ça tous les jours et je peux
vous dire que très régulièrement c'est
insupportable pour autant je pense que
vous étiez plus dans votre rôle quand
l'affect pour moi vous avez été débordé
par vos états d'âme parce qu'en face de
vous vous avez quelqu’un que vous aimez
vous l'avez dit sauf que là on vous
demande pas d'être le frérot le pote
là vous êtes l'animateur le présentateur
et à ce titre là vous devez vous
comporter comme ça et moi je sais qu'ici
on peut tout dire alors comme eduardoise
a sorti une petite formule tout à
l'heure de Jean-Paul sat juste vous dire
quelque chose qui pourrait vous aller
très bien de Voltaire je ne suis pas
d'accord avec tout ce que vous vous
dites mais je me battrai jusqu'à la mort
pour que vous ayez les droits de le dire
c'est ce que vous faites
systématiquement un bémol près
l'insultez pas Cyril un insultez pas
c'est un peu comme le coup
de boule de Zidane aussi il a il a pété
un câble voilà il dit je le regrette pas
mais j'en suis pas fier alors comme je
peux vous dire un truc je peux vous dire
que les autres copains de l'équipe de
France lui en veulent toujours et ben
aussi
avec moi